and the Oscar goes to Ben Affleck and
well
Matt Damon and Ben Affleck are childhood
friends they appeared together in
chasing Amy and grew
hunting which Damon received the Best
Actor nomination this is their first
Academy
yeah I just said the Matt losing would
suck and winning would be really scary
it's really really scary you know we're
just really two young guys who were
fortunate enough to be involved a lot of
great people whom it's coming upon us to
there's no way we're doing this in less
than 20 seconds who on who upon whom
it's incumbent of us to thank Harvey
Weinstein who believed in us and made
this movie Gus Van Sant's for brilliant
Direction Robin Williams who delivered
some straight lines many drivers
performed to plain stellan skarsgård who
was great your brother my brother Casey
who's brilliant in the movie Cole Hauser
my mother Matt's mother the most
beautiful women here my dad right over
here and Jack said Heidi yes and I John
Gordon from miracle and Chris Moore best
movie and with Patrick Whitesell the
best agent Hollywood aircraft of rifle
and Cuba Gooding for showing yourself
give our acceptance speech and all our
friends and came and everybody back in
Boston watching us said thank you so
much the city of Boston and and God I
know we're forgetting something whoever
we forgot we love you thank you thank
you so much